[Music]
get ready for more cone zones on
Charleston this time a project to
improve the street and sewers is kicking
off between Rancho and MLK Madison
Kimbrough joins us live tonight with
more on the slowdowns you can expect
Madison
yeah Sasha you can see the lit sign
behind me letting people know exactly
when the road work's going to happen and
it's starting tomorrow the people that
we spoke to say that more construction
means more headaches for drivers take a
listen yeah I use this road to go to
work and I'm gonna have to make some
adjustments now I didn't know it would
be 18 months that's crazy Christian
kokka planning his next move as he just
found out the city's plan to reconstruct
the roads and sewage line along
Charleston from Rancho to MLK starting
Monday the area will have 24-hour Lane
restrictions for the duration of the
18th month project kopka and others feel
as if Vegas has become its own
construction zone a lot of places here
in Vegas right now are just like
completely under construction and it's
definitely making it a lot harder for us
definitely locals getting to where we
need to go I go to UNLV via the
university here getting to school is
definitely going to be much harder from
widening the sidewalks to adding street
lights and bike lanes and upgrading
traffic signals on Rancho the work will
include Rehabilitation of a 45-inch
existing sewer pipe and seven man holes
and on Charleston a water main
replacement and sewage and storm drain
improvements will be done Daniela
parente acknowledging that the work
needs to be done but not looking forward
to driving in the midst of it I take my
daughter to school every morning and
yeah you know the congestion is already
bad as it is
and the project is funded by the city's
sanitary sewer Enterprise fund it is
budgeted is to cost about 38.5 million
dollars again that road work starts
tomorrow on Monday reporting live
Madison Kimbrough 8 News Now